Okay,
we are back live.
Hi.
So, uh here is the the plan for right
now. One more stream today only live for
an hour.
All we want to do right now, I don't
even know why I streamed this, but I
feel like it. I guess we're just going
to revise the
not that overleaf.
Let's go take a quick look at the RLC.
Uh
recommended limit of eight strict limit
of 12.
Okay, that's fine. So I have extra room.
So in that case,
Hey, James. How's it going, man? Yo, I'm
actually I'm back in uh Palo Alto in
couple weeks, I believe.
Yeah, I will be there for a few weeks up
until RLC and then I then I will be back
there afterwards.
Meet up if you're still there.
I'm just editing up the uh the
manuscript for RLC right now. This was
accepted. It's completely outdated, but
it was accepted. Uh I think I'm just
going to add like this one paragraph
versioning note and then like I can't
get one paper accepted and publish a
different one. So, I'm just going to add
this versioning note and then I'll make
the poster for 3.
Bagel time. Yeah, my entire diet for
while I'm there is going to be Izzy's
soul and maybe a little bit photochow.
Going to be the entire the entire meal
plan while I'm there.
Going to have to run the dish a little
bit.
I had a bad knee. I got to find I got to
find a good PT in the area.
Not near Palo Alto. Doesn't charge an
arm and a leg. Like good. I can run the
dish.
Hey, Ann. How's it going? What'd you
find with 2048?
using planning. Pretty cool. I think PO
is all you need. Wait,
hang on. It seems to be limited not by
training time, but rather by model size.
Magictor, you missed the earlier stream.
There was another stream before this.
I can get it to train to 300
score. Wait,
is that 300,000 or is that 300,000?
Huh?
You have it to 300,000.
I'm going to want to see the details of
that. This would actually be a very very
useful thing for research because
usually model size scaling doesn't help,
not what I showed in the UI. Counts for
all the new tiles created.
Wait,
20k is basically how does that make
sense? Because the tiles have to be
added together.
I definitely want to know what the
biggest tile is that it made.
This is absolutely useful. Um,
if we can actually I'm actually kind of
surprised that you get this to work
because like the optimal uh learning
rate usually changes with model size and
like usually if you keep the same
learning rate it'll collapse if you make
the model too big.
How big of a model did you use? Can I
ask?
Wait, you you only had to go to 512?
Did you train for super long or what?
Can you link me curves in uh the
Discord?
two to the 14 which is 16k.
Okay. I've seen people actually get that
score. So yes, that makes sense.
Train for like an hour. How many steps?
I want to see curbs on things.
Oh, you used the SPARS that I swept.
Okay, that makes sense then
because those were like 600 mil or
whatever for 2048, which was pretty
fast. So, I could see if you train for
longer, you could do better. And then
maybe there is a capacity limit at some
point. Huh.
I'll post screenshots since I don't know
how to share w
I'll take a look. How long will you be
here today? Until 6. Magader
give positive
review only. This is accepted. This
paper's already accepted which is why
I'm writing it on I'm doing this on
stream. This will be at RLC. Uh I will
be there in person
and
uh the poster will not be on 20. So what
I'm going to do because we released a
new major version and it's kind of
stupid to give a poster presentation on
an outdated thing. Like I can't rewrite
the whole paper right now and like
submit a paper that is different from
the one that was accepted. Uh, but I
think what I can do is I can update the
poster for the latest version. I think
that that like people will generally be
happy with that and then I can have this
versioning note here because then it's
like all this stuff has still been peer
reviewed. It's still been accepted and
then the poster we get to show off our
latest like progress since then because
otherwise it's just it's dumb to wait an
entire another cycle. Well, there won't
even be another cycle, frankly, because
I'm probably not going to submit any
more manuscripts.
Like, getting this thing published was a
total nightmare. Like, this got rejected
from Nurups, I think it was maybe once
or twice, and then it got rejected from
RLC on like by an LLM last year. So,
I'm sick of the writing process. It's a
massive waste of my time. But, we
already had this one, so I guess we do
it.
Let me go see the annex thing.
You only did five bill steps.
That doesn't look like 16k.
Oh, it's log scaled. Yes, it is. Okay.
Are these different model sizes that you
wrote me? Let me see.
Yanick, are these different model sizes
or what are these three different runs?
Why did it get rejected from NIPS? Cuz
reviewers are dumb.
This is a very very strong scaling
result then Yanick like
huh
probably with bigger models. Yeah.
Well, it's still going up like
Wait, dude. That's not log linear. Why
did you do this?
Wait, wait, wait, wait. Why did you log
scale the y- axis, dude? No, no, no, no,
no, no. You don't do that. Why? Why
would you log scale the y- axis?
Can you resend me this with the y-axis
not log scaled? I want to make a point.
Yeah, definitely send me that PR.
You can PR the the hypers that you
copied in as well.
But send me that plot real quick. I want
to make a point.
Didn't log scale. Look at the look at
the y axis. Right.
Oh, wait. Am I reading this wrong? Hang
on.
I read this as an eight cuz it's clipped
off.
Okay, my bad. But this isn't 16K, right?
This is
this is like 7K, right?
Yeah, this is a cool result. Yanick, we
should we can do this for longer for
sure. I we definitely are going to run
follow-ups on this. PR uh PR something
so we can see the real
the real score.
Yeah, PR this so that we can see the
real score if this is not it for some
reason.
Hey Finn.
Yo, did you get the uh the drone kit?
Yeah, it's all here. Sweet. Uh, I don't
know if he joined the Discord, but if
you message Jackson, I think some of the
stuff that you're trying to do with like
hooking up um Beta FOV or whatever, he's
probably done.
But I think you
you actually probably should chat with
him on that stuff. There like will be
useful things there.
Pushing my stuff would be too cool to
test with bigger models. Yeah, I can set
that up for you real quick. Let me make
sure I have this done because I don't if
I don't finish this now, I will forget
and then the deadline will pass for
this. Let me finish this. This is super
quick. But make that PR right now
And then I have to use where is it? The
camera ready.
Then I have to do I have to add my
name to this.
We don't need the superscript because
there's only one
Hey, do you have any advice for figuring
out what you want to focus on in CS?
Rising senior here. Then a lot from
FPGAAS, ML hardware, analog chip design,
bit of LML and LM in robotics. Never
really found a spark in anything. Am I
cooked? Hardware experience is pretty
rare actually. Like hardware experience
is cool. Uh that's not super common.
You kind of got to like find what
interests you though. Um I mean I can
speak to reinforcement learning and the
stuff that I do around here, but uh in
my case like I did some work in natural
language processing. I did some work in
computer vision. I actually got really
depressed with it for a good couple of
years just because like a lot of the
research was just very incremental and
uh it didn't really feel like there were
any new fundamental big paradigm shifts
in anything other than kind of just
scaling compute which was cool but like
kind of tough to do and like it it felt
kind of crappy in research to be
beholden to the amount of infrastructure
required. Uh, and then I started on RL,
right, which was very different. And I
kind of found my thing there.
There's so many different problems to
work on at the moment, frankly. There's
so so so much stuff that you can do. I
mean, we're interested in like figuring
out a ton of different domains to apply
RL to right now, right? That's like very
broadreaching.
Obviously, LLMs are hot. If you're just
thinking about where jobs are at the
moment,
hardware is going to be incredibly big.
It's the backbone of everything, right?
There's a lot of opportunities pretty
much. Not everywhere you look, but most
places you look
any file says hidden. Okay, cool. I will
try that, Yanick.
Wait, do you think we have to replace
SGD?
I'll have to read the paper.
I'm going to have to see if it's
actually a strong case. So, like
Ken Stanley does a lot of cool things.
Um,
but he discounts a lot of like practical
empirical evidence I would say like very
often. I've spoken with him several
times. He does really cool stuff though.
No, like no shame to that, but like
there's some practical things that we
know that aren't theoretically
supported, but that it's still very have
very strong empirical evidence.
Where the hell did this versioning note
go? Oh, this went to like some weird
thing.
Okay, we'll get rid of this because like
they just they don't have a good
Yeah, this is not going to do well.
Let's just we'll put this on the
homepage. The paper is single author. It
is a single author paper
was the earlier version as well when
really nobody else was involved.
I can't change the paper to 3 Yanick.
It's like it's a different paper at that
point than the one that was submitted
and reviewed. Not to mention, it would
be a ton of work. So, I'm going to put
this versioning note.
Okay, this will be published and then
the poster that I present will be 3
because it makes sense to update the
poster if not the manuscript.
Oh, I forgot this was actually a good
paper. I forgot that this was the paper
that I actually made this one good. All
right. Okay.
Man, this is like better to read than
other like the other papers I've
written, but I'm still bored reading
this.
Can you what you can do to what can you
do? It's a technical implementation
paper.
I Yeah, but like I do the same type of
stuff in my blogs and it's better, you
know?
Like the thing is the peer review
process means like you have to almost
write defensively.
So like this was like the way that this
paper is written is actually it's very
hard to get a paper published this way.
We kind of just p like we sort of just
pushed this through by brute force. And
in fact, literally one of the reviewers
say that it's like, yeah, this paper's a
tour to force. Uh, it doesn't really
give the evidence, but like I don't
doubt that the result is there. And
ultimately, the evidence that is in
paper is just like putting a table isn't
really evidence. The evidence is the
source code anyways, which they say they
have. So like we accept this. Um,
yeah. I don't know.
And the thing is it's like I do kind of
give the evidence like I I discuss all
the things that make the thing fast,
right?
I kind of give you the blueprint.
Well, there aren't any for like you
wouldn't have any formal proofs for
this. It's empirical.
and neural MMO 3 was in this as well,
right?
Yeah, Neural MO3 is in this. How come
you're still publishing?
No, it's the fact that like I wrote this
paper a long time ago. Like this paper
is 2.0 0 was from last summer and like
basically I wrote this paper for puffer
10. It was like actually a paper for
puffer 0.7 and this is just how long the
conference cycle is. So basically I've
had this paper for the last over a year.
I'm not publishing anymore. It's that
like this is literally left over from
that long ago. Any advice for puffer
plus super slow M 20 SPS? I've been
increasing update epochs and batch
sizes. What are you doing that's 20
steps per second? Finn,
what are you doing?
But yeah, Yanick, there's not like
if the publication process were sane, it
actually would be chill to just like
submit a white paper on each puffer
major version. Like just spend a day or
two writing a white paper. But the thing
is it takes longer than that and you end
up like going through three cycles
before you actually get something
published. So it's just there's no
point.
Like literally, this paper was
originally made on 1, updated to 2, and
by the time I'm going to present it,
we're going to be like a decent chunk
into 3 0 like after having already fully
released it.
Yeah, you're kind of just screwed at 20
steps per second, man.
like
Like we will eventually do stuff on
sample efficiency algorithmically
but 20 steps per second is too slow even
for that.
We add that note.
Oops.
Put it on the cluster and train it for a
week.
Let's do the math on that just to show
you how ridiculous that is. Yanick.
All right. So, we have 20 steps per
second uh times 3600 seconds per hour.
Okay. Times 24 hours time 7 days.
That's 12 million steps in a full week,
which is 3 seconds of training uh with
Puffer Lab.
So, one week or 3 seconds for a puffer
lip.
This is how much of a difference like
actually doing your engineering makes.
See, a first person environment like if
they had a capable renderer,
okay, what they could do is they could
probably get like 20 to 30,000. We'll
say 20,000. And now we're at 12 billion
steps. We can work with that.
Okay,
I think this is done,
right?
Yeah, I think we consider this done.
Nine and a half pages. There's a 12-page
limit, so we're good.
Go away, bot.
Go away.
Don't you know we build the bots around
here?
Wait, how do I upload the camera ready
to this thing?
any Amazon Prime Day deals you want?
I didn't I haven't looked at any of
that. Not really.
non-exclusive royaltyree.
Yep.
Common
non-exclusive royaltyree licensing.
Cool. They even have like a better
license agreement on this than uh
like they even have a better license
agreement on this.
Good job RLC on that. At least the uh
I'm still not happy that they tossed my
paper with an LLM last year,
There we are.
That is submitted.
Seconds to go. Perfect.
All right. We are all set for RLC.
Uh
I have got to run for dinner.
I am traveling tomorrow
for the day and then I will be in
Florida for a little bit. I will be
streaming from there and then I'll be in
Palo Alto. I don't have a good stream
set up for Palo Alto yet, but I will I
will make something work. Uh plan for
the next little bit. Got some
applications to work on. We've got
drones. Actually, I gota chat with you,
Finn, a whole bunch about drone stuff,
I'm sure. Got drone stuff to do. Got the
new drone sim. We've got the tactics
sim. Uh we've got driving stuff. There
tons and tons of different sims. And
then hopefully I'm also going to be
taking tons and tons of meetings while
I'm out there. And then hopefully
relatively soon get back to starting on
some of the core research again. I think
that'll be most interesting for people.
Also, the uh the new article is done
All I have to do is add some images to
it. So, uh, this is 25 pages of content
of pure educational content for you guys
between this one and this one. Uh, these
will both go live as soon as I hit 10K
on X. So, you can go ahead and follow me
here. Only 300 to go. And, uh, if you
want to help us out for free, just start
the repository on GitHub and join the
Discord to get involved with dev.
Uh, Yanick, I will be mostly in Palo
Alto just taking a bunch of meetings and
also avoiding the ridiculous humidity
that is here in July in Maryland. All
right. Uh, yeah. So, if anybody's there,
I'm more than happy to meet up. I will
be in Palo Alto for the most part and
kind of go to SF though way better to do
mountain view worker.